-Guys, it's time for
"Good Name, Bad Name,
Great Name."
Here we go.
-♪♪ Good names, bad names
♪♪ Great names, yes ♪♪
[ Cheering and applause ]
-First up --
That's the theme?
[ Laughter ]
It's always been?
-1, 2, 3.
-♪♪ Good names, bad names,
great names, yes ♪♪
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Happy.
First up, we have Bad Trip
That's...
[ Laughter and applause ]
Next, there's Wipeout.
[ Laughter ]
Eh!
-Oh!
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Wow.
-[ Laughs ] Wipeout.
-You wrote that one?
-I did.
I wrote that one.
[ Laughter ]
-After that we have --
I mean, it's a little
political for you.
-Well, you know,
I like to preach.
You know what I mean?
[ Laughter ]
-It's time to get
off the soap box sometimes
and do some comedy, you know
-I get right on the soap box
and I let my views out there
[ Laughter ]
I like to be po-li-ti-cal.
Sayings right and left.
You know what I mean?
-You put zingers --
-I wrote that squirrel
joke, too.
[ Laughter ]
-You wrote that one?
-Yeah.
-I wrote that one, too.
-Did you really?
[ Laughter ]
-When did you --
-That's nuts!
That's nuts!
[ Laughter ]
When I was in the sack.
I wrote it when I got up and -
[ Laughter ]
It was fun writing it.
-Yeah. What was that?
-It was fun writing it.
-Yeah. I mean, it was
a good hang, either way.
[ Laughter ]
I had a ball.
You know what I mean?
[ Laughter ]
-Me too.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
After that, we have --
Is there anything after that
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, there's good name, right?
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
After that, we have CDC.
-Come on. That's great.
"See DC."
-No, no.
-Okay, wait.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-CDC.
You don't have "A."
-Yeah, you don't have "A."
CDC.
-Yeah. Next, there is
Leave the Door Open.
[ Laughter ]
-Aw.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Don't scare him.
-That's uncalled for.
-Next up, we have Thunder Force.
[ Laughter ]
Oh, wait a minute.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Wow!
-Next, there's One Too Many.
[ Laughter ]
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Oh!
-Snap!
-After that, we've got...
[ Laughter ]
[ Laughter and applause ]
-$1,000?
-Yeah, well, it's organic.
-One grape.
-Yeah.
It's organic, though, man.
1,000 bucks.
-Alright.
[ Laughter ]
-Finally, we have...
That's all the time we hav
for "Good Name, Bad Name,
Great Name."